the anger on beirut streets
shows no sign of stopping a cataclysmic
explosion
and now a deepening political crisis
which has left the country
dangerously without a government
and this was the moment the prime
minister hassan diab threw in the towel
handing his resignation letter to the
president
soon after he appeared on television to
explain why the government had collapsed
and made an astonishing and depressing
confession
of tear gas we've just had the dramatic
resignation
of the government but it hasn't done
anything to quell the anger here
on the streets you can see the riot
police moving in now
to clear the protesters
they are vowing to continue with this
until they bring the entire rotten
system crashing down
the blast of the port has taken
lebanon's economic
and political crises to a dangerous new
level
this country is divided by 18 sects
and somehow each sect picked some kind
of warlord that fought in the civil war
and they shared everything and we
we so it doesn't matter whether it's
this government
or whether it's the past government
designing the system is what
you want yes of course yeah and what do
you want in its place
i mean it's we want uh we want a
revolution
the destruction is everywhere but with
calls of revolution growing louder
rebuilding this city of ruins may be the
easy part
a new government could take days or even
weeks to pull together
but more of the same will not be enough
to fix this wasted place
this is probably the the most dangerous
moment in the history of this country
unfortunately the the options we have
today are
are very grim if there isn't a serious
will from the international community to
create a
serious structural change in this
country we are going
for civil war what's a new lebanon would
look like
nobody knows but getting there will not
be easy
the country is now entering a period of
political darkness
and great peril lies ahead alex rossi
sky news beirut